drives and offensive rebounds but
surprising because people think of them
as a three-point shooting team but to
have that kind of advantage there in the
paint it's incredible
seven offensive rebounds eight second
chance points for the warriors hey don't
forget fanduel's free over under contest
is back so put your takes to the test
while you watch tonight's sixers jazz
matchup head to fanduel.com
over under to make your picks and
compete for a share of five thousand
dollars
in prizes as curry goes to the line
sixers and jazz the second
of our doubleheader on tnt tonight kevin
harlan and reggie miller
standing by in salt lake city
and that's a tough one there sixers
trying to get by
without joel embiid it's been difficult
and utah's defense over the last four or
five games has tanked and so they're
still going a little bit both teams
needing to win tonight in that second
game
great night first of all great
movie without the basketball there but
when kevin durant gets into the paint
with his length and touch it's pretty
much automatic
[Applause]
curry for the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
andre iguodala
on the floor for the first time back
with the warriors
all of his teammates rave about what he
has brought back to the picture is curry
[Applause]
look who's there for the rebound that's
peyton
curry again almost the same spot oh
rattles one home
four for four from three-point range on
fire pulling up from deep in transition
two guys guarding him it doesn't matter
at all when you try to play on top of
durant with the ball out top they're
just going to throw them all over the
rim you just can't do that long range
three
well blake griffin's getting tired of
this switch
i think that's the third one that curry
has hit on him tonight curry
is the game leader with 17 for both
teams and griffin is on curry and he
just can't stay with him and curry goes
all the way in and griffin just ran out
of gas
third quarter but it's the defense as
well yeah wiggins denies harden right
there
warriors plus 11 and rebounds in the
first half as curry goes as stephen
curry
gets to the basket scores with the left
hand the warriors off to a good start
here in the third quarter i will break
that story right here on the air hey
tied your own tie tonight coach
well you're not sure about that
not verified certainly everybody else
well i saw joe jacob sitting courtside
he was a little he was cringing when he
saw steph curry and start taking that
charge oh curry
a minute and a half into this fourth
quarter
curry lets it fly and right to the
bottom it goes now do you know how hard
that is right there now he got him set
curry hits the three
they're back up 21. their defenses look
better the last two possessions
drip drip
sharp
curry perry's still on the floor damian
lee up ahead lee looking for someone
finds the right someone and curry knocks
it down
37 points